everyone understands the extraordinary
hardships that are placed on the
uninsured President Obama is right no
American should have to choose between
getting health insurance and paying rent
between getting health insurance and
getting groceries I was going to get
health insurance that I got drunk
between getting health insurance and
getting drunk got a nice bouquet with
the wife stood between health insurance
and designer jeans with white stitching
a black man we spent a lot of money on
clothes between health insurance and
bodybuilding supplements I work outs of
supplements and stuff cost me like three
hundred allah's month vitamin is
coaching hockey not a mean we hear so
much about hardworking Americans who
need insurance but what about the rest
of us why do I not have health insurance
because I live in America millions of
uninsured Americans could afford health
insurance but it would mean going
without some really cool stuff that's
not going to have a mighty sick and sad
I'm a bit allows that support President
Obama's plan to cover all Americans
because no American should have to
choose between health insurance and
protein powder we should have health
care to dickies